>> THERE ARE MORE IMPORTANT
THINGS THAN COMFORT.
>> Tucker: DAVE RUBEN, HE HOST
THE RUBIN REPORT ON YOUTUBE.
HE JOINS US.
AS I AM WATCHING MAD, I HAD THIS
PANIC FEELING.
MAYBE I FELL FOR AN ELABORATE
IRONIC PRANK AND THEN I REALIZED
KNOW WHERE THEY DON'T HAVE A
SENSE OF HUMOR.
REASSURE ME.
THIS IS REAL.
>> TUCKER, VERY QUICKLY ON THE
LAST SEGMENTS.
I THOUGHT YOU WERE THE
HIGHEST-PAID MAN AND TELEVISION.
I AM SHOCKED.
I DON'T GET PAID FOR THESE
APPEARANCES BUT I AM GOING TO
MAIL YOU A CHECK FOR SOMEWHERE
BETWEEN 15 AND $20.
THAT ASIDE.
THESE PUFF PIECES, THESE PIECES
THAT THESE AUTHORS WHATEVER THEY
ARE, JOURNALIST.
THESE ARE NOT PIECES OF TURN
ALLOWS                OF
JOURNALISM.
IF YOU WATCH RUDOLPH THE RED
NOSE REINDEER AND THINK IT IS
ABOUT MISOGYNY AND RACISM.
YOU CAN FIND THAT STUFF
EVERYWHERE.
IF YOU LOOK BACK AT ANYTHING.
THAT IS WHAT PEOPLE THINK YOU
UNDERSTAND.
YOU START LOOKING AT SOMETHING
THAT YOU USED TO LOVE HER THAT
USED TO HAVE A WONDERFUL MESSAGE
ABOUT THE HOLIDAY AND GIVING AND
BEING ACCEPTED IN ALL THOSE
THINGS.
THEY ARE TRYING TO TAKE THAT
AWAY FROM YOU.
IT IS NOT WITH A STOP WITH ONE
THING.
THEY FIND SOMETHING THEY
DESTROYED THAT THEY WILL MOVE ON
TO EVERYTHING ELSE THAT WE LOVE.
EVENTUALLY THEY WILL MOVE ON TO
SITCOMS
SUCCUMBS THAT WE LOVE.
WHETHER TO SEINFELD OR FRIENDS,
THEY WILL GO TO CARTOONS.
THEY PLAN FOR BUGS BUNNY.
THEY WILL LITERALLY GO FOR A
SUNSET.
THINK OF SOMETHING YOU LOVE THAT
BRINGS YOU A SENSE OF PEACE AND
DECENCY AND THEY WILL SOMEHOW
LINK IT TO THE PATRIARCHY AND
THE REST OF THEIR POLITICALLY
CORRECT NONSENSE.
WE JUST NEED TO REALIZE AS I
SAID EARLIER, IT IS EASIER TO
DESTROY THAN CREATE.
WE HAVE TO CREATE.
SPEW AND THAT IS SUCH A SMART
POINT.
WHAT ARE WE CREATING?
WHAT IS BEING CREATED IN THIS
MARK OF DESTRUCTION.
MAKE ME FEEL BETTER.
>> THAT IS WHAT I AM WORRIED
ABOUT.
THERE IS AN LEGITIMACY THAT SOME
OF THE THINGS HAPPENING IN THE
COUNTRY IN THE WORLD SHOULD BE
DESTROYED AT SOME LEVEL.
WE HAVE MAJOR PROBLEMS AND
ACADEMIA.
WE WANT SOME CHANGE.
ANYONE CAN BURN ANYTHING DOWN.
THE QUESTION IS, WE PUT UP WITH
SO MUCH GOODNESS IN THE WORLD.
UNITED STATES AND WESTERN WORLD
HAS PUT UP SO MUCH GOODNESS.
WE LIVE IN THE FREEST COUNTRY
EVER.
GOOD WHATEVER WE WANT AND IF
YOUR JOB IS TO WRITE PIECES THAT
ACTUALLY DESTROY THE STORIES
THAT WE ARE BUILT ON AND THEY
DON'T OFFER AN ALTERNATIVE.
THAT IS THE SAME.
THEY NEVER OFFER AN ALTERNATIVE.
IF THEY DO IT IT'S ABOUT POWER
TO THE STATE WHICH IS ACTUALLY
DYSTOPIA AND NOT UTOPIAN.
THAT IS WHAT WE HAVE TO WATCH
OUT FOR.
IT IS UNFORTUNATE.
THEY WRITE THESE THINGS AND GUYS
LIKE US, WE FEEL WE HAVE TO
RESPOND.
>> Tucker: I AM GLAD THAT WE
DID.
YOU JUST ISSUED A CHALLENGE TO